An operating system provides applications with access to
the underlying hardware.
It does so by exporting a number of services.
At the most basic level,
these services are directly linked to some of the components of the hardware.
For instance, there is a scheduling component that's responsible for
controlling the access to the CPU, or maybe there are even multiple CPUs.
The memory manager is responsible for allocating the underlying physical memory
to one or more co-running applications.
And it also has to make sure that multiple applications don't overwrite each
other's accesses to memory.
A block device driver is responsible for access to a block device like disk.
In addition, the operating system also exports higher-level services that
are linked with higher-level abstractions, as opposed to
those that are linked with abstractions that really map to the hardware.
For instance, the file is a useful abstraction that's supported by
virtually all operating systems.
And in principle, operating systems integrate file system as a service.
In summary, the operating system will have to incorporate a number of
services in order to provide applications and
application developers with a number of useful types of functionality.
This includes process management,
file management, device management, and so forth.
Operating systems make all of these services available via system calls.
For example, here are some system calls in two popular operating systems,
Windows and Unix.
I will not read through this list, but notice although these are two
very different operating systems, the types of system calls and the abstractions
around those systems calls these two OSes provide are very similar.
But process control, creating a process, exiting a process,
waiting for object, creating files, etc.